amidst all the rubble of the latest
Russian strike on the capital fire Crews
pull out a survivor
his hands grip his Rescuers as he's
carefully lifted to safety
this is what life is like for those
living in the city right now an attack
can come out of nowhere Anytime Anyplace
this explosion was substantial
and captured on the car park CCTV
it was one of several bombs to hit the
capital city overnight
but shortly afterwards photographs began
circulating on the internet which
appeared to show the shopping mall with
military vehicles parked underneath it's
not clear how recent these photographs
are or their origin
but British intelligence reports
suggests the Russian military is
intensifying its attacks on key
the capital is still thought to be
Russia's key military objective and
defense officials are warning the troops
will prioritize attempts to encircle the
city over the next few days and weeks
there's still fears fighting to the
north of here but while Russian troops
have stalled in their Advance on the
capital they're using long-range rocket
strikes instead to terrorize and kill
them what are they trying to achieve by
mercilessly bombing shopping malls
hospitals maternity areas houses
civilians there's military chaplain says
what do they want to achieve
I can't understand it he says
do you understand it eosis I don't think
you can
the attacks are causing terrible
destruction and spreading fear
I don't feel safe anywhere in Ukraine
she tells us
the city authorities have turned the
capital into a fortress and the Russian
troops have been mostly held at around
20 kilometers away around the perimeter
in the center they are resolutely trying
to continue something resembling
normality here
although the sudden spike in attacks has
led to a second 35-hour curfew being
imposed within a week starting tonight
and the Russian military showing they
can instill Terror and kill with these
indiscriminate attacks without setting
foot inside the capital Alex Crawford
Sky News Kiev